[Applause]
and he just goes you this is a really
good storytelling in a fight like it's
very much beat by beat here's what's
happening
she's actually just doing the move to
the stunt guy which is not okay
oh my God and puts her hand over it like
yo that's too hot this woman made a lot
of money
laughs
huge thanks to Squarespace for
sponsoring today's episode
but how difficult
Y come a professional Hollywood stunt
man the level of commitment that's
required in all of your life well
courtesy of today's sponsor Squarespace
that difficulty just got one step easier
it requires more than just being Nimble
and Incredibly good looking it requires
an online presence and with
squarespace's beautiful award-winning
templates that's exactly what you'll get
you see Squarespace has everything you
need to get your online presence up and
running in 2023 including simultaneous
posting which allows you to post once on
your Squarespace website and have that
post simultaneously go out to all of
your social media profiles
Squarespace also has video blocks and
audio blocks which allow you to post
video and audio assets directly into
your website they also have best in the
game analytics which allow you to
understand who's coming to your site
what pages they're viewing and how to
make your site better over time head on
over to squarespace.com corridorcrew to
get 10 off a first purchase of a website
or domain that's squarespace.com
Corridor crew and now
let's get stunting ah yo what is up
happy Saturday it's us on the couch and
you know what that means another episode
of stuff and react we got the true o to
the G Eric Linden with us on the couch
today and of course Nico hi also an OG
and we got some awesome Clips let's just
dig in right yeah let's just go right in
for the Undisputed UFC middleweight
title first fighter to the scale the
Challenger Elwood Dalton so I got to do
the new Road House movie so I was in the
Dominican Republic for like about three
months was Dublin Jake Gyllenhaal and I
can't say a ton about it I think it
dropped maybe 15 pounds just got super
lean to go out there and do this movie
and there was just a ton of water work
as you can see there they're on the
beach so there was a lot of Precision
boat work and just having an entire crew
all out on the water where you would
have 10 12 boats go 45 minutes out into
the ocean and then you need to operate
hair makeup camera all this stuff on
boats was logistical nightmare
definitely made it made it difficult but
hopefully it makes it awesome also very
different movie than the one that Swayze
did
[Music]
problem there's no problem I've actually
never seen Roadhouse food or not oh
really how dare you
awesome stiff hook kick yeah you know he
does a spin kick to send the guy out the
window which is hilarious but you know
back in you know the 80s when you're
watching this that was amazing yep but
Swayze was like a real martial artist he
definitely trained it a lot and like
kind of knew what he was doing I mean
it's got that like nice brawl feel to it
yeah
oh good gag you know like the floor
wasn't padded they're just like going
for it he got to wear some elbow patches
you can see them
boom see Swayze when you look at his
punches boom bang he looks good I mean I
think that they just use the take of him
kicking that looked bad but he could
kick yeah it's just a distancing like
look at that look at that
across his face
that punch right there just completely
missed yeah air needed to hook that a
little bit more
yeah
that ass like if you have a hairy chest
like you definitely leave that extra
button I wonder if these hairstyles are
going to come back in I'm wondering when
people are just going to kind of start
wearing the left earring again you know
it's happened they used to be like the
tough guy thing that was was like
everybody had the house he's so edgy
that was a good that was a good fall
there's a time in martial arts cinematic
history where nobody kicked to the face
ever it wasn't a thing it was also a
time where there were no kicks like
kickstarted happening like closely
around the time of Bruce Lee that's when
kicks actually happened in film
cinematic kicking and then when it came
to America it still stayed like very
much so we're kicking at the chest and
at the legs We're not gonna kick at the
head and you see it in this film a lot
learn how the kick for camera is a
completely different art style than
punching for camera also in terms of
what was hot at the time in American
Cinema that's not what people deemed as
like that was what you do like you punch
you throw people around you hit them
over the head with stuff it's usually
these bar brawls and then this is like
one of the closest Renditions we have to
like seeing martial arts kicks I mean
there were so many times like these
action movies where somebody would like
do a crushing kick and knock the gun
yeah absolutely the Crescent kick was
the disarming move watch this
and he just goes you and then jump back
down just go kicks him out of the way
get out of my way yeah yeah that stuff
from the 80s that is just awesome I hope
they bring that back in the Roadhouse I
have an NDA
[Music]
damn what an awesome stunt yeah yeah
sure he is skying through the air just
going right to the dirt that's that's
all yeah no pads yeah no shirt on just
grease
yeah baby oil and dirt when he hits the
ground it doesn't even look like he
maybe they chopped up the dirt a little
bit but I mean he just hits this yeah
yeah that's it that's the thing I really
like about classic stunts is that it's
not just a spectacle piece it's a
demonstration of like yes this is
possible here's what it would actually
look like if it were to happen like when
Jackie Chan clears you know a big gap
between two buildings he's not in a wire
because it's not magic it's no this is
actually a possible outcome they could
use to escape yeah the thing that's
great is that when you are doing
something like that practically you can
shoot it a little bit wider you don't
have to edit through it and kind of let
the action play out
prison
wow
another manly thing to say that'd be
pretty intimidating in a fight honestly
yeah so he was for that in your ear be
like whoa
some of those Stacks are really nice
yeah really good you know like Swayze
doesn't need to swing his knee way past
the guy's head like he brings it to a
certain level and then the guy takes a
reaction and then the punch that comes
right after that yeah nice cell good
timing and look at him just rolling on
him boom boom boom
and this guy just takes it too far I'm
gonna kill you the old-fashioned way
oh God go take a swim
yeah Swayze was awesome Patrick Swayze
he's a goat
gee I've never heard that before you
know I gotta say there's something about
this movie that like if you watch it and
kind of ignore some of the hairstyles
and some of the like the cheesy like
moves that happen it's a pretty darn
good movie and it wasn't cheesy then no
it wasn't at all it almost makes me want
to watch a Steven Seagal fight from the
80s oh no
I have something in my pocket right now
completely clear up that bruise on your
forehead
I'm not gonna lie like these fight
scenes are kind of cool oh no no some of
what Steven Seagal did really well was
no one had seen a lot of aikido right he
was doing these moves that really hadn't
necessarily been done on film before or
not to this level and some of the
reasons as gee said that it does look
pretty darn good is because he's
actually just doing the move to the
stunt guy which is not okay
yeah so he's really locking their arms
and he's really like just throttling
them when he puts them to the ground
he's such a big dude too he Towers over
everybody
so his power or or whatever not that I
necessarily think these moves really
would work on somebody he knows how to
do the move properly and obviously
trains a lot and and so his power when
he does throttle somebody is is kind of
not not cool
he loves hitting people in the nuts too
do you validate parking Eric Linden is
like dashing a double rainbow
oh
wow
the first double rainbow if you're not
subscribed you might miss it when he
shows up so make sure you're subscribed
hey did you guys do the react to Tommy
Lee Jones and uh Benicio del Toro no I
fight you haven't done that let's go
let's do it
have you seen this movie no oh man
we're gonna ruin it again I think
something that they did that's
interesting in this which I want you to
like kind of witness is the way they
fight
oh
oh wow so good what a move I've never
even thought about that as a technique
this is really good storytelling in a
fight like it's very much beat by beat
here's what's happening I mean so brutal
and there's something about this it's
just like you just like kind of feel it
a little bit more Super different they
are not relying on the One-Shot kill
where you just like stab somebody in the
in the fight's over right and some of
the stuff that's like really pausy where
they have some sort of lock on each
other it's that they both know like if I
let go there's like certain death right
and even the guy with the knife is like
putting pressure in a certain thing but
he knows if he tries to move and re-stab
that this guy could disarm him and then
kill him
damn oh there's another thing like this
is a bit of a trend right now with knife
fighting weapons and movies which I
don't see it here which is nice but it's
like if somebody does a swing with like
a knife and you like you block it right
I'm like I'm gonna slice you and then
just leave their arm there now if this
other person do whatever they want yeah
yeah
you know that's called Cooperative
choreography or croppy or scream
fighting there's also uncooperative
screen frame which we see a lot in
Donnie and stuff so it's the idea of I'm
giving you my arm so that way now you
can do what you need to do whereas
usually it'll be a block and now you
have to take my arm yeah and I'm not
giving it back to you and then then you
can take it that's interesting I didn't
know they had two games like that
because I like seeing uncooperative
fighting because it's harder it's more
accurate to what the characters will be
thinking it's trickier to choreograph
with but the storytelling is richer for
it oh yeah you know too often like fight
scenes are just like all right second
you can shoot that it's the song and
dance number between the story you know
whereas this is like it's the final
scene with the characters like it's
getting the attention with the actors
the pacing like it's the climax of your
movie it should be treated with more
gravitas and like care and dedication
like any other scene in the film
hey come here I know we're right in the
middle of filming stunt and react okay
but I just want to tell you that you
could at this very moment be watching
this episode on your smart TV that's
right Apple TV Android TV Samsung and
Fire TV and it's coming soon to Roku LG
and older models of Samsung TVs and as a
corridor digital member you'll also get
15 off all merch exclusive shows
including click-by-click tutorials are
Studio Vlog our DND show son of a
dungeon an extended react episode look
my point is there's never been a better
time to give Corridor digital.com a try
so head on over now there's a link down
below you can get started for just 3.99
a month plus there's a free trial okay I
should probably start paying attention
again let's go
today I'm being set on fire three two
so you've coordinated and supervised and
been in a lot of firework yeah yeah we
do this in another episode of summon
react but this is a fire stunt no CG you
know your fire stuff yeah
this
boom
Oh puts her face right into it
oh my God and puts her hand over it like
yo that's too hot that's rad that's
crazy
and boom smoke I wonder what stunt woman
did this this woman made a lot of money
oh yeah
the hallways literally solid fire
because it's like and she's bouncing off
the walls like she's bouncing into some
of them yeah like what she trips and
like it's like what happens then she
certainly got hot
you know like whether she was burned or
not I mean right there yeah there that
was bad yeah she got smoke there it
looks like some of these charges are a
little bit lower the fire rolling off
the front of the dress as she runs
forward is just like oh God it's awesome
another thing that helps out a ton she's
got this dress on and see how it bubbles
out yeah I'm willing to bet her legs are
pretty darn protected yeah you can kind
of see like on her fingers yep that her
fingers have a glove on them which they
did a great job of keeping the Wardrobe
like the Fire protective wardrobe like
skinny you're still wearing three layers
or whatever it might be but they did a
fantastic job of making sure that that
fit her well but you know the fact that
she's a Frankenstein you can get a
rubber mask that is made to look like
this gnarly makeup job and it's going to
play a lot better than trying to put on
a mask that looks like me or whatever so
a scene like this there's like two
things maybe they come out to me one is
how do you put her out right away she's
covered with layers of fabric right I
feel like it'd be very difficult to put
her out right away you know so you're
going to have a lot of people on cans at
the end of this hallway with CO2 you
know CO2 is sucking oxygen out of the
air and you know fire needs oxygen to go
so even though the fuel is still active
once there's no more oxygen the fire is
going to be put out and I'm assuming
every one of those doors could probably
pop open and somebody could come in and
save her if she goes down early that was
another question yeah what happens if
she falls halfway through that yeah I'm
assuming there's a safety that could run
in and get her if she needed to go down
and are they wearing full fireproof
suits also 100 yeah because they're
going to have to run right into that
mess it didn't occur to me that you'd
probably have all the stunt people in
full fireproof gear also like
firefighters well she's running towards
her safeties right now yeah I'm assuming
there's two safeties on either side of
camera can you see when you're in the
situation you can see but it's usually
pretty blurry she definitely has like a
Pyrex lens over top of her eye but as
you breathe in the gel also will fog up
those lenses so you're just seeing like
kind of like shapes which adds the
difficulty is all this light is behind
her although it's like kind of like
Illuminating this direction it's like
you're kind of coming from the light
source running into the dark so I think
that that probably makes it even more
difficult to see what's happening but
clearly this is this is a one-way road
so they're like just keep bouncing down
the hall so you get somebody comes and
puts you out
you guys gave a lot of great references
in the comments section that we pulled
up today that we got to really enjoy so
keep that coming and drop that video
Drop that clip what is your favorite
action sequence their action moment in
the film or television show I feel like
there's so much more that we need to go
over but we we really knocked out a
solid one this time
hell yeah damn thank you Eric all right
well thank you for watching Everybody
we'll see you in the next one peace